[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
a pas photo spécial puisque nous allons
parler vous vient de s'apercevoir aux
réalités qui a des élections
présidentielles dans un peu moins de
deux mois tout le monde s'en fout ou
presque enfin on va en parler en tout
cas on va parler de ces élections
présidentielles qui ce qui se présente
qui ne passionne pas visiblement les
français encore peut-être est-ce que
c'est la cristallisation va-t-elle
arrivée ou pas on va en parler avec
laurence maugest bonjour bonjour vous
êtes la référence comme on dit
reconquête des yvelines et reconquête
c'est le parti
d'eric zemmour avant je ne me moque pas
du tout des élections c'est bien parti
pour nous là
mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu' une
certaine indifférence peut-être on
pourra on pourra se demander pourquoi
jean charles lajoie ni bonjour bonjour
vous suivez de près évidemment ces
élections mais ça
ça me passionne aussi absolument la
maison d'édition lajoinie se porte bien
très bien très bien on sent un bolide
j'ai oublié de vous la portez la
prochaine fois on en reparlera
l'euro mazaury bonjour bonjour vous êtes
vice-président de la communauté
d'agglomération saint quentin en
yvelines vous êtes adjoint au maire
d'elancourt vous êtes membre dudit et
président de tv 78 j'ai tout dit à peu
près oui tout ce qu'ils disent ne jamais
la blood est la redéfinition et raphaël
mata duvignau bonjour bonjour vous êtes
maître de conférences de droit public à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
peut-être qu'on peut commencer par
quelque chose d'actualité c'est à dire
que dimanche il ya eu un coup de fil
très long entre
macron et vladimir poutine qui va
aboutir
peut-être à une rencontre entre joe
biden et vladimir poutine est alors va
pas parler de la situation en ukraine
qui peut évoluer d'un honneur ce qu'on
pourrait dire aux jeunes de maintenant
ce serait fou dans quelques dans
quelques jours mais je vais vous
interroger sur au fola est-ce qu'il ya
des conséquences il peut y avoir des
conséquences de cette suractivité
j'avais dire des manuels mac ronde dans
ce conflit de la position qui prend
est-ce qu'on peut pas se dire au fond si
on regarde les candidats qui pourraient
en faire autant
tout le monde
sait très bien ce que je voyais eric
zemmour à la face à face à poutine oui
parce que essentiellement airs exelmans
il a aussi l'analyse je dirais en
histoire l'histoire pourquoi ça se passe
comme ça en ukraine il faut quand même
revenir sur le fait que l'otan en cercle
à la russie depuis déjà pas mal de temps
et que la russie se sont un petit peu
menacé et donc je pense que c'est
intéressant d'avoir une analyse la plus
objective possible
historique évolutive pour appréhender un
problème
vous voyez qu'il l'avait parce que il
est encore une fois vous le savez est
pétri d'histoire donc c'est important
d'avoir une portée historique pour
prendre des positions sur l'actualité
cela dit quand même hier dimanche sur
toute l'éternité dans une émission
politique et de dean de choses qui
étaient assez incroyable dit voilà ce
que je ferais l'europe pourra comme moi
sauf que
c'est un trade avant ça s'est pas jouée
d'avancé genre de ce genre de position
c'est pas parce que le président
française est quelque chose que l'europe
je suis forcément c'est peut-être qu'une
expression je sais pas je n'ai pas
entendu en tout cas je pense qu'il a il
aurait tout à fait la ferveur d'accord
nous allons prendre position
pour répondre à votre question oui je
pense que valérie pécresse frais très
bien le job
eric zemmour pourquoi pas
qui a d'autres comme candidat et les
cadeaux alors yannick jadot chaud et ses
suppôts suivi comme nettement moins
convaincus
christiane taubira alors beaucoup non
plus à l'est de mélenchon ben melanson
c'est un peu comme zemmour quand ils
sont un peu si on peut qu rillieux avec
leurs rapports avec la russie et tout
donc moi ça m'inquiète un peu donc
disons que je pouvais les rythmes très
très bien le job quoi avaler les
spectateurs on est certain que le risque
d'un goûter car on n'a pas à se poser
cette question du point positif
les effets crès alors d'abord elle pas
le par le russe je crois donc c'est ce
qui te après près alors j'allais voilà
vous avez dit poutine qui est quelqu'un
de d'homophobe de misogyne
j'allais dire cet argument j'ose à peine
le dire mais est ce que dans
l'inconscient
français une femme aurait le même rôle
qu'un homme dans le conscient d'un
certain d'un petit nombre de nos francs
saisis pas dedans les cautions collectif
j'espère que oui
je pense que depuis les époques thatcher
en bretagne où j'espère on est passé au
delà de ça et je pense que s'agissant de
valérie pécresse il se serait le cas
pour d'autres s'ils continuent de les
compétences des personnes en question de
la connaissance y compris historique que
vous évoquez madame augès je pense qu'on
a aujourd'hui tout à fait confiance dans
une femme et j'espère qu'on ne fait plus
de différence pour le traitement et de
stationner d'ailleurs bien souvent elle
se montre beaucoup plus mesuré et plus
réfléchie que nous les a mais on notera
que les dictateurs sont en général
plutôt des hommes que des femmes c'est
vrai on aime on voit également avec
angela merkel en allemagne
c'est une femme elle est restée très
longtemps au pouvoir et elle a été
appréciée a été respectée et elle était
capable de discuter d'égal à égal avec
avec un homme que soit belle il admire
poutine ou avec un autre donc que ce
soit valérie pécresse effectivement ou
une autre femme pourquoi pas je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les mentalités ont changé
et
elles sont capables de
du coup verner et comme comme n'importe
quel homme n'importe quelle personne
pardon après au delà de ça je pense que
ce que cela met en exergue le sait le
rôle et le positionnement de la france
en europe et de l'europe dont on peut
encore peser dans le monde tant qu'on
n'aura pas eu une défense qu'on n'aura
pas une défense européenne et on sait
que depuis plus de 40 ans du travail
sans jamais aboutir et tant qu'on n'aura
pas non plus pris en compte le fait
qu'ils ont été la défense urbaine de la
france d'autant plus maintenant que le
départ de la grande bretagne et bien
c'est l'armée française et qu'on n'aura
pas pris en compte c'était peut-être une
des rares bonnes idées de françois
hollande les dépenses de l'armement
français dans les critères de
d'équilibré financier de maastricht on
aura moins de poids et donc à un moment
donné il faut aussi que la france parle
avec ce qu'elle est capable de
représenter c'est à dire aussi une
puissance nucléaire majeur mais c'est ce
qui donne du poids à la diplomatie
avait raison jamais défense européenne
mais incapables de s'entendre avec
l'allemagne qui à chaque fois torfi tous
les efforts qu'on peut faire de
construire des choses en commun et à
chaque fois c'est des allemands qui nous
lâchent les seuls qui semblent un peu
avec nous c'est l'italie et l'espagne
qui font effectivement de gros efforts
etc mais sinon il aura les pays du nord
se réfugie derrière le bouclier de
l'otan et puis les gens se disant toute
façon on à l'otan et puis on a aussi
l'europe si j'aime en a besoin donc on
est on est absolument les seuls donc
c'est pour ça que le laisser venir enfin
l'europe avance souvent par des crises
on l'avait dit avec l'élection trump
c'était en gros une chance pour l'europe
d'avoir un rôle international le conflit
entre la russie et l'ukraine c'est d'une
certaine façon aussi enfin une chose
d'une prise de conscience de l'europe de
vendée besoin qu'elles devraient avoir
une force de défense associant à ce sens
que le rend pas de la chance parce qu'il
ya eu très peu mais maintenant il ya
buydens mais je veux dire c'est comme
deux de plus il est évident qu'ils sont
quand même enfin jeudi à dubaï dalle
super kpn des gens qui commencent ouvrir
les yeux donc ces cavaliers vigneault
donc oui je voulais juste préciser que
refaite emmanuel macron il est dans son
rôle de président de la république chef
des armées responsable des relations
extérieures et puis aussi n'oublions pas
que la france ait plein depuis janvier
président de l'union européenne donc ils
en sont roule actuellement dans son rôle
tout à fait mais et puis le modèle des
résultats ne s'étonne que l'opposition
voit la journée effectivement urgence
par revenir aussi sur ce que vous venez
à monsieur je pense qu'il faut que la
france renforçant d'armé quoi c'est à
dire aussi c'est très important de
retrouver notre armée notre armée on
avait quand même une armée qui est et
qui était colossale qui était très forte
et il faut revenir à la souveraineté
nationale
d'ailleurs c'est ce que défend eric
zemmour de pouvoir se défendre avec une
armée nationale nationale j'étais
peut-être là que pour une fois zemmour
et mâcon se rejoignent secure veut
augmenter pas mal la dotation pour la
même défense nationale et mâcon a fait
des efforts énormes enfin le président
actuel va dire jamais depuis des années
le budget de la
nasa n'a été aussi élevée donc ça c'est
quand même tout à fait positif comme on
voit quand même l'utilité de d'avoir
comme vous le disiez vaincu une armée et
quand même digne de ce nom avec des
manques avec un manque de munitions avec
un manque de deux il ya encore plein de
choses qui manquent mais on avait quand
même est extrêmement compétent de des
forces des bateaux des sous marins un
porte avions fait tout ça c'est une
autre question la construction de
deuxième porte-avions qu'on a toujours
repoussé en vous pouvez pas le financer
on a vu dans la crise qu'on est en
capacité de financer d un porte avions
et puis que c'est indispensable
un porte-avions en permanence et pas
avec pas six mois sur douze ce sens ces
ajouts pas l'aide de cette crise entre
la russie et l'ukraine parce que on se
demande au fonds qu'elle avait tous les
éléments déclencheurs de cette campagne
électorale et on peut poser peut-être la
première question c'est qu'à un moment
elle laisse à son coude selon
l'expression que ça se cristallisent
c'est à dire qu'on voit les tendances on
va poser la question est ce que ça se
cristallisent
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez d'ailleurs est
ce que c'est c'est joué déjà
est-ce que ça se jouait ce que le
premier tour est incertain le premier
tour est plus qu'incertain puisque ap a
priori à l'heure où nous parlons
président macron va bien évidemment
candidat il va il y à plus de 22 % et 23
% peut-être même 24 donc ya pas y'a pas
de soucis pour lui pour être présent
pour l'instant au deuxième tour après le
l'autre candidat ou candidate c'est
beaucoup plus serré lui est compliqué
parce que ce serait tout à 15 % tous les
trois dans ce qu'on peut appeler la
marge d'erreur des sondages non qu'il y
en a peint devant lui enfin je veux dire
que ce soit valérie pécresse marine le
pen zemmour ils sont dans un mouchoir
donc c'est très difficile de savoir la
seule chose où peut-être que madame nous
en dira plus là-dessus mais je pense que
une petite tromperie avec zemmour qui
fait que beaucoup de gens comme il a été
totalement diaboliser il ya sûrement
dans les sondages une sorte de refus
même en tête à tête ou même au téléphone
à dire oui je vais voter zemmour donc je
pense qu'il est sous représentée dans
les sondages et que il est probablement
bien plus haut que compte le voilà c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé quand ils
veulent et votre casier marie le pen ya
très bien vous avec le dire et les
sondages tous mal apprécié la la force
du front national n'est pas que
maintenant on le sait puisqu'il des
élections zemmour c'est vrai que c'est
un peu c'est un peu plus compliqué et
qu'il ya des gens ceux qui sont sur le
terrain qui rapporte que thierry voit
beaucoup sur les marchés des français
qui leur disaient ils parlent un peu
durement tout ça mais peut-être que sur
le fond il dit des choses et c'est donc
on peut penser en effet il peut y avoir
un autre cachet
sans doute à votre cacher mais il ya
aussi le vote des abstentionnistes
puisqu'elle va te cacher ça ça revient à
peu près à la population qui fauteuil
pour qu'ils votent pour le pen donc on
n'ose pas dire mais y'a peut-être autre
chose
oui parce que j'ai envie d en citer je
veux pécresse et qu'ils voteraient le
pour ne pas dire que vous trouvez vous
oui et
yahia il ya plus que ça il ya des gens
qui sont abstentionnistes depuis des
années parce qu'ils sont déçus par la
politique etc avec zemmour représente
quand même enfin il vient d'un autre
milieu et il n'a pas vu des combats
politiciens il s'est pas frotté à ce
monde là il vient d'un milieu
intellectuel il était en effet dans les
médias et c'est très différent donc il
n'a pas toutes ses casseroles et je
pense que ça peut réveiller des ça peut
réveiller des français patriotes qui ont
envie enfin de voir en eric zemmour un
homme qui incarne la france et qui est
très qui revendique son patriotisme
oui enfin on pourrait dire ça de
beaucoup d'autres candidats aux
fourriers exado site est plutôt nouveau
politique
c'est pas c'est pas que la nouveauté qui
peut qui peut attirer les
abstentionnistes il pense pas
si vous regardez on en parlera peut-être
tout à l'heure de l'image des candidats
elle et elle est quand même assez dans
l'ensemble assez assez négative que ce
soient égaux ou d'autres
rafale mais je pense qu'en fait il ya
plusieurs qu'il ya plusieurs
problématiques à prendre en
considération / c'est sur cette
cristallisation premièrement et ça on
verra dans début mars qui sera qualifié
au premier tour déjà qui sera qualifié
pour être candidat parce qu'on se trouve
à point pour l'action des parrainages
voulant s'en est à ces défis difficiles
pour sa part s'attendre de candidats
donc les choses se cristalliseront
vraiment au moment de la d2 la liste
officielle ça ses premiers éléments
deuxième élément concernant le vote cash
eric zemmour je ne sais pas j'ai pas
d'opinion vraiment trancher maintenant
effectivement je pense qu'à des
personnes nées d'une incertitude oui
parce que même la longueur romain me
désire a effectivement qui voteront pour
zemmour après je crois aussi qu un
certain nombre de sondages se font par
internet et il ya aussi le fait que
l'anonymat libère la parole d'une
soldate qu'il ya aussi les descendeurs
le fait que finalement avec avec
internet on ose dire que l'on votera
pour preuve les mots pour n'importe qui
d'autre est là où je vous rejoins c'est
que le
les sondages d'opinion vis-à-vis de eric
zemmour c'est comme marine le pen ou
comme aux enfants marie le pen avant ils
étaient diabolisés lui été diabolisé
elle un peu moins et maintenant
finalement c'est eric zemmour qui est
diabolisé par rapport par rapport au
front national donc c'est vrai qu'il ya
cette marge d'incertitude et puis il ya
aussi les gens qui pensent qu'ils sont
convaincus ou qui ont des opinions aux
proches d'eric zemmour mais peut-être
qu'au final au moment de voter peut-être
qu'ils changeront donc effectivement il
ya cette marche se votre cash et c'est
toujours ce week-end à huy réflexe de
l'urne giscard d'estaing mais qu'il y
avait cette théorie en 91 10 en bas au
dernier moment mais mitterrand est passé
devant dans les sondages mais les
l'entourage des escarres disais au
dernier moment ils râlent réflexe de vue
on c'est à dire que les urnes aux roues
pas mettre le bulletin ils voteront
jusqu'à sa s'est pas produit quand tu
vas tomber le mythe l'espérer vous avez
tout à fait raison sur le vote cacher et
c'est pas c'est plus marine le pen ce
n'est une telle haine dans les médias
une telle diabolisation d'eric zemmour
que ces mêmes médias sont en train de
béatifier marine le pen c'est à dire que
marine le pen pour moi c'est le même
personnage
jamais vu autant dans les médias invités
partout
j'ai plutôt l'impression que c'est au
contraire non ceux qui sont qui sont qui
sont au service de zemmour mais avait
mal compris je me suis mal exprimé ne
s'est pas dit qu'il n'était pas sûr les
médias j'ai dit que les médias le
haïssait est pressé de dire que c'était
sûr que ces news le
a beaucoup plus attaquées sur l'image
qu'on a de lui que sur ce qui est dit
vraiment mais bon ce que je voulais dire
c'est que marine le pen
benzema tandis que moi je regrette juste
beaucoup qu'on ne s'attaque pas plus à
ce qu'il dit parce que je sens qu'ils
équipent plutôt dangereux gueule et
justement ce que j'aimerais c'est vrai
mais mais en fait on reste sur les q
monsieur truc
canalisations il il est là et des
réseaux par est un peu ça fait filet les
émissions sur ces news quand même ou des
façons quand ils vont servir de deux
ennemis parce que c est trop sérieuse de
canon sur bfm pardon je peux citer fm et
sur wii mais justement on dit aussi que
ces news et en gros l'atelier de d'eric
zemmour mais tout ça c'est de la
caricature et sa détente ou des études
que réalistes ont changé vous avez des
gens comme mathieu bock-côté comme ça
qu'ils sont qui sont quand même
timide par rapport à bfm par rapport aux
chaînes aux chaînes nationales enfin il
y est quand même avec sa lame et il a
été comme une très très mal traités très
après elle a rétrogradé ce que de toute
façon ils devraient comprendre que c'est
que c'est contreproductif parce qu'au
bout d'un moment quand on essaye la
grille millet quelqu'un comme ça les
français vont finir par se rendre compte
que ya anguille sous roche on peut pas
manipuler et dépenser les réflexions des
défenses haye pourquoi il a le droit de
s'exprimer on est en démocratie
s'exprime enfin ce nom non alors
j'essaie de si je veux un petit peu
prendre de la hauteur par rapport à tout
ça c'est ce qu'on peut noter déjà c'est
qu'il n'y a plus de candidat crédible
aujourd'hui s'il n'est pas portée par un
média quels qu'ils soient et quand été
la candidature d'eric zemmour vos parce
que au départ au départ il ya un
marche-pied médiatique qu après
effectivement les médias ce retour n'est
pas ce que j'appelle la du buzz vous
faites vous du papier en critiquant un
jour ce qu'ils ont pensé la veille c'est
assez traditionnelles mais eric zemmour
n'existerait pas ce niveau si finement
il n'avait pas été portée au démarrage
par ces émissions et c'est ce qui lui a
donné fait un porte-voix avait la
manière de s'exprimer est évidemment
bien sûr évident qu'ils n'ont pas sont
moins connus et même si m aimait mes
idées ne réprimant pas pris et donc le
rôle des médias ont leur voix ça a été
le cas avec la candidature d'emmanuel
indiqueront pour le coup à l'époque avec
bfm ou rappelons-nous les caméras de bfm
suivant le candidat macron absolument
partout donner une impression évidemment
qu'on cherche à avoir dans un meeting
quand on réunit trois mille personnes
qui ont fait en sorte que les caméras
soient le moins large possible pour
donner l'impression qu'elle à 300 milles
c'est la même chose les médias ont eu ce
rôle l'aï loué avec les zemmour ils
l'ont eue avec avec les mêmes macron et
regardez ils ont même eu depuis une
dizaine de jours un peu ce rôle avec
fabien roussel donc laïque d'un coup il
ya 1,7 alors parce que alors après à
provenir sur qu'est ce qu'un bon
candidat mais on n'a pas raté tout à
l'heure est ce qu'un bon candidat celui
qui est un bon programme des bonnes
idées ou celui qui a une belle terre
les médias du coup incarne un gros est
ce qu'un bon candidat ou une bonne
candidate c'est avant tout une actrice
et du coup j'espère que nous
allons évidemment sa défaveur parce que
effectivement c'est pas une bonne
actrice enfin en tout cas c'est
l'impression qu'on a eue lors de
l'avant-dernier meeting donc du cosy
comme c'est pas une bonne actrice a peut
pas être une bonne présidente mais ça me
semble être on se fourvoie on n'attend
pas d'un président ou une présidente que
ce soit un bon acteur ou une actrice on
attend ce qu'il y ait du fonds et pour
finir quand à la cristallisation tant
que le président macro ne s'est pas
déterminés et n'a pas dit je suis
candidat et voilà mon programme je vois
pas comment on peut cristalliser
puisqu'on ne sait par par exemple
puisque on voit bien que le combat
serait beaucoup sur le régalien en tout
cas à droite zemmour très régaliens
valérie pécresse attaqué sur son
discours justement très régaliens
suivant ce qu'il va aller chercher du
côté de la sécurité
effectivement des affaires extérieures
et des affaires intérieures et du
traitement de la justice ça aura
forcément un impact sur le
positionnement et la cristallisation des
autres candidats donc on est aussi géré
aujourd'hui il attend la parole du
président les homosexuels oui pardon à
toutes les prestations d'eric zemmour
sur ces news c était aussi un travail de
fond c'est à dire que c'était pas qu'un
travail d'acteur donc historique donc
c'était finalement il a progressé dans
nom des idées pendant tout ce temps là
en rencontrant beaucoup de gens beaucoup
d'acteurs de la politique et donc il
s'est formé il s'est forgé une
expérience importante donc c'était pas
alors je le peux desvres préciser quand
j'ai dit il faut un bon acteur avec du
fond mais si vous n'avez pas le média ou
le porte voix nécessaires on votre voix
parce ça je sais rien ne passe pas et
c'est en ça que dans l'absolu beaucoup
d'eau d'ailleurs on l'a vu à d'autres
époques où des journalistes pas patrice
lair nous ici présents mais où donc se
sont lancé en politique à gauche a été
très longtemps sur france 3 parce
qu'évidemment vous arriver qu'une pomme
de terre
noël demain voilà je préfère lui
évidemment vous écraser ou jean marie
cavada afin que ça nous écraser
effectivement les autres puisque vous
êtes déjà connu et donc vous partez avec
un avantage est évidemment vous avez
raison madame angèle s'il n'y a pas de
fond ça c'est violent très rapidement
mais si vous avez le fonds et vous avez
le porte-voix le marchepied au départ le
résultat est juste vous êtes tout de
suite à 15 voilà on y est on vous ai
tous eus à 15% ce que les autres
n'arriveront pas à avoir parce qu'ils
n'auront pas ce portelois tellement il
était connu avant d'être connue avant
d'être candidat est d'ailleurs
s'interroger entre les médias qui y ont
intérêt à soutenir un candidat et les
médias qui ont intérêt à
mettre les projecteurs je suis un
candidat parce que celle leur rapporte
ddd tatin de téléspectateurs ce qui
était aussi le cas d'emmanuel ma peau
c'était la curiosité de l'époque enfin
et c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois jacques à
l'élection présidentielle gagne il faut
une curiosité
mélenchon c'est la même logique c'est un
demi d'enseignants et donc quand on est
vite sur un plateau on sait qu'il va se
passer quelque chose à piolenc et je
suis désolé alors pas tv 78 et sur les
autres chaînes on est là pour vendre
aussi ce qui se passe entre deux
émissions la publicité il valait pas
d'audience journée pas de publicité je
trouve que jean luc mélenchon cependant
le meilleur porte-voix pour la publicité
entre les émissions la curiosité cette
année c'est roussel quoi parce qu'il
faut toujours de parmi les candidats
sortent de deux gars sympa joyeux
thématiques et qui est d'autant plus
sympathique et joyeux qui est là est
absolument aucun risque il arrive
deuxième au premier tour ni même au
deuxième donc il est là il a une très
bonne idée la france heureuse vive le
bonheur la côte de boeuf le kill de
rouge et le camembert enfin certains
c'est merveilleux ça c'est vraiment bien
avant c'était la salle puis la salisse
un peu noyé dans ces il ya quelques
années mais maintenant il a repris ce
flambeau du passé les dents si je me
permets l'eczéma refait des audiences
tout à fait remarquable et sur le dessus
d'une façon je dirais neutre et
impartial on pourrait déjà être content
qu'ils fassent une pause l'audience au
très chic totalement neutre et impartial
évidemment mais c'est tout moi je suis
sa soeur c'est intéressant qu'il kiffe à
cette audience là parce que ça veut dire
que les français c'est pour ça qu'il
disait que les médias dans l'obligation
qui soutiennent et il ya ce bio voilà
qui ont intérêt à faire venir des gens
dont ils savent qu'ils vous faire de
l'audience il n'y a pas que d'intérêts
je dirais j'espère quand il ya aussi le
fait qu'il est important que tout le
monde puisse avoir la possibilité de
parler qui en assure une certaine
pluralité grâce à ces news maintenant
quand même à eghezée mort en effet à une
double vie on ne l'entend pas tâche dans
ces nouvelles mesures
si longtemps qu'ils ont en partie sur
ses lieux ses partisans disent ils ce
qu'il avance et c'est ce que je voulais
dire après tant mieux juste je reviens
pendant un petit peu en arrière sur ce
que vous viviez raphaël c'est dire que
oui on saura qui allaient parrainage est
pas alors là il ya un vrai débat puisque
alors comme à chaque fois
le pen faisait ça à chaque fois en dix
ans je n'aurai pas les 500 signatures et
à chaque fois de les ont tous ceux qui
disent qu ils n'ont pas eu raison a
généralement mais c'est vrai que il ya
un débat aujourd'hui sur cette règle des
500 signatures de maires au début
de notre ami bayrou le modem de françois
bayrou en effet ce qui est de dire voilà
on va mettre un matelas de deux
signatures de maires de cannes c'est
très bien la dre le 10 mai du site
disney a vu alors c'est très bien ou pas
très bien parce que l'on pourrait
traduire dire la règle c'est d'avoir 500
signatures si vous désirez pas pour vous
présenter mes séries c'est de la
démocratie mais démocratiquement
vous laisser dire ça
imaginez que marine le pen mélenchon et
s'ils sont pas capables d'avoir 5 s'il
ya un déficit démocratique absolument
monstrueux va dire il ya mes rafale et
est beaucoup plus experts que moi mais
mais cette règle des 500 fait elles
datent un peu du moment où c'était les
100 signatures certes elle est claire et
les skis qui votaient pour le président
de la république alors après on leur dit
c'est plus lent ici ça donne ça dan
salas dix ans sa date exactement de ça
on a laissé du pouvoir au maire donc
voilà si plus vous qu'elle est nommée
mais enfin voilà les cinq sens
et pour la transparence
souris ce qui s'est passé à saint ce
temps et au long des situations a voulu
celle là plus de logique il est plus
logique se soumettrait pas normal qu'un
maire qui dit je donne mon parrainage
ax tel ou tel candidat ça soit public
c'est quand même des choses seul geste
d'achat soit publique je dis simplement
que c'est curieux de ces curieux on a eu
un début
c'est méconnaître la réalité des back
offices de la politique ça je suis assez
d'accord que après tout révèle qui le
veut à qui il donne son parrainage mais
que ce soit obligatoire au public ça
pose un problème en fait c'est assez
facile quand on est david lisnard je
félicite de ce qu'il a fait de dire je
donne mon parrainage à mélenchon parce
que il risque entre guillemets à rien
mais quand on est maire intermédiaires
dans des petites collectivités qui
dépendent d'eux au moins 70 % de leur
budget des dotations différentes à
savoir le département à la communauté de
l'agglomération le pci enfin je dis pas
qu'on le vit mais on le sent et que
éventuellement ils dépendent aussi de
leur parti pour dire tu auras
l'étiquette la prochaine fois où tu ne
leur a pas je mettrais un candidat en
face de toi ou je n'en mettrai pas la
liberté elle est très très très relative
et et essayer dans tous les partis la
même chose c'est tout et c'est même plus
encore pardon encore plus vicieux c'est
qu'à un moment donné c'est ce sont les
partis qui décide quels seront les
candidats des autres partis en force on
leur a tiré parti du tour suivant c'est
ce jeu là qui pose problème même si je
comprends bien et moi je partage l'idée
que tout le monde sache qu'ils sont
maîtres soutien sauf que les effets
induits humain parce que c'est que de
l'humain et les calculs derrière sont
juste des terre dévastateur non mais
vous avez raison aussi c'est que on est
dans le secret de l'isoloir en tant que
citoyen quand on va voter et pourquoi
est-ce qu'on demanderait une
transparence au maire avait rien il ya
un vote qui doit expliquer ce qui les
pins le disent ils aux écoles cela dit
s'ils le veulent je passe pardon c'est
ma maladresse on voit beaucoup sur
twitter en ce moment par je prends le
cas de valérie pécresse il beaucoup
effectivement de mer qui ont là ils
prennent en photo ils remplissent sans
papiers là je pars est valérie pécresse
ils le font volontairement s'ils veulent
pas le faire qu'il ne le fasse pas elle
est obligée bois francs franchement je
vois tellement d'effets pervers au
système aujourd'hui alors et en plus
jamais témoin jeu des transparences je
rajoute quelque chose c'est au nom de
quoi d'ailleurs considérerait ton que
l'on devrait donner des parrainages à
des candidats qui apparaîtrait dans les
intentions de vote dans les sondages
s'était on retombe sur le débat d'avant
ceux qui sauraient était connu par les
médias et qui donc du coup parce qu'il
saurait à 8% de voir leurs parrainages
mais au nom de quoi c'est pas le c pas
logique c'est pas non plus logique on ne
doit plus se plaindre que celui qui a vu
bon sens les sondages dépasser 500
signatures appartement où l'on
considérait donc que ferait la
présélection des candidats l'impact des
sondages ça marche pas non plus la seule
solution c'est de revenir ou de mettre
en place à nouveau un anonymat et ceux
des cartes qui le veut et là on est dans
un système comme vous le disiez dans
lequel tout le monde a sa chance on sait
qu'avec l'anonymat et le la question des
500 signatures c'est réglé mais bien sûr
mais évidemment alors mais absolument
mais c'est une évidence totale vous
savez on le voit dans ce qu'on appelle
les votes dans tous les aidants tous les
dans tous les endroits où on doit voter
dans les conseils départementaux et ses
passions le vote et public à main levée
c'est amusant les résultats sont pas les
mêmes que quand on passe sur des
scrutins mais évidemment mais bien sûr
parce que vous êtes pris dans un groupe
je pars pas la soie nationale ya une
obligation de voter par groupes dans les
autres instances il ya toujours des
moments où vous avez envie de parler
indépendamment de votre parti vous vous
pensez différemment et d'autant plus que
vous êtes élu local je tu il n'ya pas
une différence fondamentale dans une
ville de 8000 habitants entre le maire
qui ait eu délit le maire qui est sans
étiquette le maire qui est à droite le
maire qui à un moment donné quand ils
doivent décider de comment va se faire
la collecte des ordures ménagères je
pense pas qu'ils aient une orientation
particulièrement trancher entre les
différents partis on est dans du concret
et ben oui mais quand on passe au cran
supérieur
évidemment les intérêts sont différents
et par conséquent sur votre tête
influences de toutes ça avait été fait
uniquement pour contrer le front
national c'est
par le vêtement et uniquement ça
beaucoup de gens dans l'équipe je peux
vous assurer que cette pression est là
s'en faut revenir à l'anonymat c'est ça
bon c'est ça la démocratie parce que
sinon il ya des pressions la piscine à
attendre
si celui-ci attendait des années je
continue parce que juste quand on voit
que anne hidalgo a peut vendre des
promesses de parrainages elle n'aura
bientôt plus de parrainage que des
lecteurs cc c'est pathétique enfin c'est
pas du tout normal il ya vraiment le
système de perception à sa décharge et
de la démocratie ça après tout
si zemmour a passé parrainage ou est ce
que il pas capable d'avoir 500 maires
qui se
pose la question je l'aurais je vais
vous répondre parce que quand on est à
15 % dans les sondages et quand on n'a
pas de parrainage ça pose question et
quand et quand on sait que et quand on
sait que le parrainage rassis c'est
aussi les élus locaux c'est aussi c'est
pas c'est pas que c'est pas que les
sauvages mais dans la mesure où dans la
mesure où on ne consomme pas dépendants
de leurs décisions alors qu'on disait
pas ça oui je vous suis si anonymat il
ya de nîmes à eric zemmour c'est le tour
des maires pour ces équipes ont persuadé
par rapport à ces rames et elle veut
dire les là les élus s'est choisie cela
ils peuvent pas jouer en réalité peuvent
pas choisir mais c'est facile quand je
veux dire ça aujourd'hui parrainage mais
vous c'est plus compliqué si c'est lui
le nombre de mères qui nous en disent
le nombre de mères qui nous dit ce matin
des on est d'accord sur tout avec eric
simon mais je peux pas c'est
excellent mais parce que ses idées sont
indicibles non ses besoins ce qui est
acceptable ce détail l'édition c'est que
vous n'êtes pas au vide soucie pas du
tout pas du tout
wade ou est les falaises comme ça
après ce sont des contraintes
politicienne de terrain c'est encore ce
qui est intéressant de papin ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir que on se
focalise sur sur trois quatre candidats
qui sont effectivement assez haut dans
les sondages par contre d'autres
candidats qui sont très très bas dans
les sondages ont obtenu leur obtenir
fectivement pour
la pression effectivement par contre
j'aurais dit qu'ils sont plongés rappelé
que c'était pour un maire est ce que
c'est moins lambert dans ce plaisir de
dire je soutiens la candidate lutte
ouvrière que de dire je soutiens
ce sont des usa seraient vous pardonnez
l'expression probablement sont des
candidats que j'appellerais mascotte
c'est à dire que sont des candidats qui
pour lesquelles on a une sympathie quel
que soit le bord politique et finalement
ils font du bien et ça sentait le gaz
vers cette vague exactement jean
lassalle à nathalie arthaud
effectivement fric fou tout je sais plus
où vidéo je sais pas où il en est les
boutons beaucoup plus de mal il a du mal
oui par contre sur le plan juridique
effectivement il ya une ya la réalité du
terrain là je suis parfaitement d'accord
par contre le parrainage n'est pas un
soutien c'est simplement une caution
c'est une caution effectivement mais je
j'entends moi je place vendôme
effectivement ce n'est qu'une caution
donc qu'un maire soutif un parraine tel
ou tel candidat snav ça ne veut pas
normalement dire qu il le soutient
politiquement mais je suis d'accord avec
vous l'anonymat est peut-être plus à
lutter au nom d'une cause sur une banque
sur un projet s'ils vous donnent la
caution séquelles croire votre projet et
donc du coup je soutiens le projet 5,2
mds
quand même 40 est sorti parce qu'à cause
de ça il savait très bien qu'en berline
à main il ya entre le parrainage de
soutien capable de donner leur signature
après c'est vrai que si un candidat
n'est pas capable de réunir 500
personnes sur 42 milles mais aussi dans
l'absolu vous avez toutes les raisons ça
doit être ça c'est à dire que
normalement le parrainage ça devrait
d'ailleurs pacte et ce à un
accompagnement à la candidature ça
serait peut-être mieux ça c'est pas un
soutien mais dans la vente à ces régions
les noirs avec l'initiative de quand on
tourne la roue et du et du maire de
cannes cela que probablement dénervaud
vont apporter des soutiens à messieurs
ont fait des calculs politiciens par
exemple on pourrait imaginer que les
roms auraient intérêt effectivement à
s'assurer que votre candidat et ses
signatures on peut se passer c'est leur
problème mais c'est pas sincèrement que
c'est passé il faut sortir tonnes poids
là patricio et un moment on disait que
valérie pécresse aussi aurait intérêt ce
que zemmour soit là pour prendre à
marine le pen après les calculs ils sont
toujours
et surtout jour ils sont toujours
compliquées c'est à dire les parties de
poker
mais c'est vrai
il fait le lit fait baisser marine le
pen donc c'est tout bénéfice pour
valérie pécresse c'était avant que
ciotti soit candidat et fatigant la
conséquence rendre compte que la broye
voilà non mais alors parlons de valérie
pécresse votre
parce que lui dei continue à soutenir
malgré le grand place
un débat fort de willy pour revenir sur
ce sujet entre le président à la gare d
elle même et je pense que les choses ont
été réglés en tout cas oui je crois que
jean christophe lagarde lui a demandé de
sortir les facéties de son expression un
démo de l'extrême droite oui de
l'exploit du complotisme et devant le
temps l'occurrence salariés aient eu
quand même c'est pour ça que je parlais
de la cristallisation parce qu'il est
quand même ce meeting du zénith qui a
fait beaucoup parler
et qui a entraîné quand même une baisse
dans les sondages dans certains sondages
se retrouve valérie pécresse à 12% c'est
à dire qu'ils avaient une baisse en même
temps il vint croisement des courbes
avec avec eric zemmour
est-ce que c'est jouer ou pas je sais
jouer c'est jamais joué ensemble et
jouent à demander des coupes comme ça
quand ça quand cette mort en tant que
candidats commencent à baisser à monter
quand vous donnez moi avant les
élections généralement c'est un signe
non mais ça peut changer d'abord ça te
change et parce que je vous crois
qu'elle a réorienté son discours tout de
suite après on a vu le son son meeting
de cette semaine ce n'est pas du tout la
même chose sans notes sans prompteur un
peu plus improvisées comme ça c'est le
premier point deuxième point c'est aussi
celui que je disais tout à l'heure tant
que président n'est pas arrivé qu'on n'a
pas le propre du président je n'ai
aucune idée de ce que peut donner les
convois jusqu'ici parce qu'une partie
des déclarations de candidature d'
emmanuel macron peut le faire baisser
dans les sondages
c'est toujours un peu ce qui se passe
ils perdent systématiquement 4 à 5% dans
les sondages le jour où il se déclare
candidat donc ça peut jouer et il a du
coup s'il y en a un qui qui monte est
lui qui baissent ça veut redevenir
compliqué de savoir qui sera présent au
second tour dans ce qu'elle pensait
qu'il ya un risque que le qu'il soit pas
au second tour
parce qu'il ya quand même stabilité sur
les intentions de 1 6 1 6 2 6 4 avant
pour son intention de vote il ya bien
quelqu'un qui va récupérer les camions
sans donc quelqu'un qui était à 16 peut
arriver avant donc c'est un seul
candidat qui les ont dispersés pas non
mais ce que c'est pas assez pas il rien
n'est gravé dans le marbre point ça
c'est vrai que c'est pour ça que je
crois que tous les candidats sont
unanimes pour dire il faut maintenant
que le président se déclare parce que ça
devient un peu c'est vrai que là ça
devient un peu ridicule qu'on est mais
quand même à moins de deux mois de
l'élection et ont fait semblant dans le
parti ils passent leur temps à tracter
c'est un public en mars ils traquent
pour un candidat il dépose même d'un
point de vue du droit je comprends même
pas comment on peut arriver à déposer
des signatures pour un candidat qui ne
l'est pas
cerutti
justement c'est la conscience le permet
on maire peut enfin maire ou un élu peut
parier qu'il souhaitait françois
hollande a
renié
michèle bernier n'avait jamais dit
non alors qu'il s'est expliqué jeudi bas
dans le marasme de la gauche je vous
souhaiteraient que françois hollande
représente cette année c'est pour ça que
la classe ou du médoc il ya oui en effet
des parrainages qui vont à des candidats
qui ne seront pas candidats c'est le
conseil constitutionnel qui demandera à
chaque candidat qu'il ya 500 signatures
est ce que vous acceptez ou pas après ça
c'est le lait candia qui doivent envoyer
de les trains au conseil constitutionnel
pour dire qu'ils n'acceptent pas d'être
candidat on n'attendait pas une
déclaration de françois hollande il ya
une ville un peu plus de trois semaines
il avait dit je vais j'ai fait une
grande déclaration je vais dire où j'en
suis ce que je fais et c'est là je crois
que verser sinon sa candidature parce
que je vois qu'il a un but dans la vie
c'est de faire battre maquereau
et le deuxième c'est norbert d un idéal
dans les familles où l'on s'était grande
tradition on parlera d y avait des skis
on était ont été reconduits un petit peu
sur valérie pécresse
c'est vrai que ont l'impression que la
campagne a été plombé par l'omniprésence
et la force d'eric ciotti comme une ode
à la frange droite de la plomber je ne
sais pas l'objectif du centre et de la
droite a toujours été de faire une forme
de synthèse même si c'est aujourd'hui
eric zemmour qui soit en revendant chez
synthèse tombe là il faut marcher sur
deux pieds il faut marcher à la fois
effectivement sur une politique
économique qui soit structuré pro
européenne et dans l'intérêt
majoritairement de toutes les
entreprises françaises parce que c'est
elle qui génère des emplois et pas le
est pas le monde public et puis
deuxièmement il faut effectivement être
fort dans le régalien et ses deux pieds
là sont toujours assez difficile à
difficiles à concilier donc je peux
marcher sur ses deux filles quand on est
obligé de faire le grand d'été car c'est
plus difficile d'avancer quand même
olympus table
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on fait pas
forcément un grand écart d'ailleurs
puisque la volonté des primaires aura
prend pour avoir un débat spécifique de
savoir si les parties doivent continuer
cette chose chose que sont les primaires
qui quelque part nous
éloigne des débats de premier tour en
été on est quasiment juste rasseoir qui
sera au deuxième tour et on attaquait
débat deuxième tour est probalement que
l'erreur que nous avons commise dans ce
meeting c'était d'être déjà dans un dans
un meeting de deuxième tour avant
d'avoir réglé le problème du premier
tour voilà mais je pense que l'
équilibre existe aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il ait trouvé le poids d'eric ciotti
il est aussi positif parce que après
tout il faut aussi rappeler qu'il faut
pas s'éloigner cet aspect régaliens
parce que un des enjeux pour valérie
pécresse est pour pour eux et leurs élus
dei c'est justement de se démarquer mais
hier claire par rapport aux gramounes
emmanuel macron je pense que cette
démarcation ne se fait pas tant que ça
sur le domaine économique il se fait
plus sur le domaine régalien mais en
même temps quand on est sûr domaine
régalien on doit pas aller vers des
théories qu'ils soient purement
d'extrême droite c'est là où on doit
être vigilant et garder cette forme d'
équilibre ce que le rpr à l'époque et le
medef avec l'âge j'ai appartenu savez à
mon avis mieux faire que les partis en
place aujourd'hui en plus avec des aces
que ce nicolas sarkozy avait fait la
synthèse d'ailleurs c'est un vrai sujet
on attend la parole de françois hollande
mais on attend aussi celle de nicolas
sarkozy on n'est peut-être pas au bout
de nos surprises le concernant calmement
il va parler du commandeur va descendre
de quelques matches que va-t-il dire et
à quel moment va t'il à dire voilà
effectivement en tout cas se précipitent
pas hop non il n'ya pas dire pourtant il
a été sollicité mais voilà s'il nous
entend il peut éventuellement appelé tv
78 on passera en direct et je pense
qu'on sera heureux de réaliser chaussée
grand plaisir ce qui va dire mais je
montrerai son attachement télévision
locale je sais qu'il est très sensible
aux télévisions doivent donc ces bons
qui nous prouve le le problème pardon je
reviens sur cette campagne c'est vrai
qu'on a eu l'impression
alors peut-être à tort parce que sur le
grand remplacement en effet on doit fait
dire quelque chose qu'elle n'a pas dit
mais il ya aussi l'expression français
de papier qui était qui était celle de
jean marie le pen car prises et pécresse
on a eu l'impression qu'elle allait
quand même chasser sur les terres d'eric
zemmour il ya quand même cette vieille
règle politique qui veut que l'on
préfère toujours l'original à la copie
et que quand on prend les thèses qui ne
sont pas les siennes pour aller
chasser sur les sur les terres d'un
autre on favorise plutôt l'autre que soi
même et on le voit un peu dans les
magasins qui est la copie et l'original
je veux dire elle est l udf existe
depuis plus beaucoup plus longtemps que
j'entends bien je parlais de deux
français de papier je parlais de
référence aux remplacements qui était
quand même là pour le coup tout au des
thèmes d'extrême droite le grand
remplacement on est d'accord patrice que
c'est parce qu'elle à dire non
mais voilà le fait de le fait de parler
de reprendre l'expression a été oui sont
mal interprétés je vous parlais nicolas
sarkozy tout à l'heure au sein de l'ua
père à l'époque les propos de nicolas
sarkozy sur les problématiques du
traitement des migrations la mise en
place des quotas l'identité nationale il
date alors évidemment d'après marine le
pen mais ils ont à mon sens toujours
évolué indépendamment du front national
de l'époque et du rassemblement national
d'aujourd'hui valérie pécresse est dans
la même logique la chance de la chance
par des fautes de
de nicolas sarkozy en 2007 c'est qu'il
avait face à lui
une extrême droite représentée par mme
le pen 10 ans ce qui est un peu moins le
cas avec est la présence d'eric zemmour
et la présence de je sais pas quels que
soient les partis on peut pas considérer
demain aujourd'hui que tout ce qui
touche à la sécurité nationale d
identité c'est la propriété du parti x
ou y et moi j'aimerais et je l'entends
parfois on prend le cas de fabien
roussel qui nous donne ses idées sur
comment réguler effectivement les
migrations en france quels sont les
quotas acceptable ce qu'on doit mettre
des quotas quel typologie d'immigrés
nous voulons accueillir quels sont ceux
qu'on veut pas accueillir quelle
stratégie on veut mettre pour
éventuellement renvoyer gens chez eux
quand on a les accords nationaux qu il
n'empêche c'est à dire des choses
intelligentes et structuré plutôt que de
dire on va renvoyer tout le monde chez
soi alors qu'on sait que c'est pas
possible c'est certes des annonces qui
sont très intéressante et très
sympathique mais qui n'ont aucune
réalité au moins dans une position de
valérie pécresse de quelque chose qui
dit voici le champ des possibles moi
quand j'entends sur la partie de la
sécurité intérieure alors sur tous les
plateaux dire il faut plus d'ouvrir la
police il faut qu'ils aient la police
arrête plus et on fait quoi des gens
qu'on a arrêté on l'aimé ou pas ce qu'on
nous dit qu'on sur les prisons qui vont
avec et nous et nos députés de tous les
partis oublie de modifier la loi pour
permettre effectivement que ces jouets
sont condamnés dans des accélérations
intelligente dans des conditions dignes
d'incarcération que on focalise tous sur
les moyens de la police certains y en a
besoin on focalise ralliement et la
justice certes ok très bien et on fait
quoi de l'application des peines mais on
sait tous très bien que le parquet est
obligé obligé de donner des instructions
de gestion économique de l'incarcération
qui fait qu'on retrouve dans les rues
des gens que la police arrêtait pourquoi
c'est la logique hiérarchique qui vaut
décembre cette logique hiérarchique elle
est bâtie sur des problématiques
économiques stratégiques politiques moi
j'entends ce genre de choses c'est
valérie pécresse j'espère j'entendrai
seul autre candidat et ça me semblait
plus intelligent en tout cas plus
structuré il ya le faisable il ne
faisait pas ce qu'on peut modifier vous
êtes un peu responsable de ça en tant
qu' en tant qu'élu en tant que maire en
france il faut quinze ans pour
construire une prison pourquoi parce
qu'un systématiquement quand on propose
de construire une prison le maire dit ah
oui celle les prisons c'est bien mais
pas chez moi et j'ai dit a
systématiquement dans n'importe quel
autre pays on peut construire une prison
aux quatre ans je veux dire c'est par
cet acteur allemand c'est pas très
compliqué contre une prison mais non en
france faut 15 ans est allé recours l'ex
été mais c'est donc saisi ce qu'était un
socialisation das arriver
et
la jeune sur joint le gaspard koenig oui
simple et en dentelle et les français
signature parce que la
simplification sélection
même façon mais c'est moi souvent gêné
j'ai plus envie qu'on construise devrait
désormais des faits lui merci oui je les
ai mort qui a mis dans le débat public
ne prenne le souci de l'identité de la
france et de la sécurité c'est quand
même lui qui portait ça avec des
solutions qui sera justement de cette
terme du grand remplacement parce que
moi j'ai toujours pas compris quoi ce
qui laissait khwaja et cent mille
immigrés chaque année en france avant
qu'il fasse le grand emplacement il
faudrait je sais pas que d'abord que
qu'ils ne meurent jamais ensuite parce
que pour que ça s'ajoute aux les uns aux
autres ensuite que les 50 minutes
français fassent leurs valises et
aillent ailleurs pour pour qui le grand
remplacement je n'ai toujours pas
compris je suis pas le seul ddd les
démographes comme hervé le bras ce 10
mai s'est complètement
fantasmatique il faut il faut surtout
résonné sur le sable c'est à dire que je
conduis escaut dairy farm uk cake et le
père de ce gros emplacement qui
entendait faire est un écrivain un peu
sulfureux mais bon très très très vite
comme ça très j'emprunte
la baisse est un écrivain quoi c'est par
exemple
ce qu'ils aient une porte
il n'est pas le père du grand
remplacement c'est celui qui l'a
identifié et alors il faut tenir compte
aussi des beloteurs 2 de l'expression
pavot et c'est vrai qu'il faut tenir
compte surtout du solde c'est à dire
qu'il faut là quand on en compte les
immigrés qui arrivent et on on enlève
les immigrés en fait les personnes qui
quittent la france il faut tenir compte
uniquement des immigrés qui arrivent et
quand on a quand même des yeux qui
savoir on peut se rendre compte en effet
que vous pouvez pas je travaille et ne
pas tenir compte de ce qu'ils ouvrent il
ya beaucoup dans le don dans l'arrivée
des immigrés il y en a beaucoup qui le
oui ils sont les messages qui sont vos
très vite sans mal les académies qui de
la france il ya aussi des gens qui
chantent +5 et qui quitte la france en
tout cas en tout cas je pense que quand
on est dans certains quartiers et quand
on voit ce qu'on voit on se rend bien
compte quand même que qui a beaucoup que
la population change il ya des quartiers
où on n'a pas besoin d'être grand clerc
pour s'en rendre compte donc il ya un
problème de le 2 met en avant je trouve
que c'est tout à fait courageuses et de
pouvoir en parler et je pense qu'elles
exhibent leur force toute la classe
politique a soulevé ce problème et à le
regarder en face je pense que c'est il
ne dit pas qui il est il est pas du tout
contre des immigrés il est contre des
immigrés qui n'aiment pas la france
c'est qui renie la france qui ne qui
font du mal à la france et délinquants
les gens qui qui sont pour les
délinquants y ait qu on dit de mêmes
même date et lire tous pour ce pas
favorable et lingots et pas dire si vous
prenez ça va quand même plus que ça ce
qui est dit
je pense qu'il faut pas non plus tout
mélanger il ya aussi des termes et des
mots que personne n'ose plus employé
parce que dès qu'on les emplois
visiblement on vous menace de vous faire
écouter la tête quand on voit leur
reportage qui a été diffusé sur m6 sur
roubaix on peut pas nier le fait qu'il
ya quand même un certain changement dans
le tissu urbain à roubaix donc ça c'est
peut toujours dire tout ça n'existe pas
ça existe donc ça c'est vrai moi je le
vois je donne des cours
limité de rambouillet je veux dire ça
fait 20 ans je veux dire j'ai il ya 20
ans j'avais pas d'étudiants de voiles et
j'ai des étudiants de voile et donc nous
ni aux passagers c'est pas un problème
mais c'est une réalité donc ça existe
alors diversité vous avez le droit
d'être voilée à l'université c'est la
loi française je dis pas qu'on a le
droit que sa parole il ya 20 ans j'en
avais pas maintenant il y en a c'est
tout non mes questions pratiques c'est
dire si vous pouvez dire de temps en
temps il faut admettre la réalité est
que ce qui se met alors à la presse que
j'ai nommé six cerveaux et française
aucune question ce qui se passe à
roubaix ce qui se passe dans certaines
banlieues
non mais c'est vrai qu'il ya des
quartiers
soient bien des quartiers monsieur vous
ça vous pose des questions oui c'est
surtout une question de nombre c'est
toujours une question de nombre on dit
qu'au bout d'un moment la quantité se
transforme en qualité c'est ça le sessad
soucie réellement c'est à dire que je
crois que c'est très important et très
salutaire pour la france lesquels non je
voudrais terminer jallier jusqu'au bout
de mon idée sinon j'ai pas y arriver
donc je pense que c'est très important
qu'eric zemmour ait le courage le cran
de dénoncer sainte de dire il y a des
possibilités pour en effet que la france
devienne musulmane à jour c'est possible
ça s'est déjà vu dans l'histoire ça peut
se reproduire
donc maintenant on peut s'en moquer on
peut dire bon ben voilà c'est la vie les
peuples change des civilisations meurent
mais voilà nous ont géré millions 800
mille de musulmans aujourd'hui donc
j'allais y avait un tiers qui vaut un
thierry van khê kiki van acker mosquées
comme le temps encore de francky région
à cela il faut rajouter à ça notamment à
léogâne et la force et ont une aussi le
fait que la france se dénigrent depuis
quand même des décennies et l'éducation
nationale je crois que c'est signé merci
que l'éducation nationale fait en sorte
qu' on ne met pas en valeur la france
comme ça a été fait en génération
passé à l'école donc il y a une mauvaise
image de la france aux yeux des enfants
et en même temps il y à une civilisation
qui est très forte qui elle comment dire
est très fort de scanner défend ses
valeurs et qui arrivent dans notre pays
donc on peut se poser la question on ne
dit on ne met pas en place on ne veut
pas décidé et des comment dire avoir des
idées inhumaines c'est pas du tout le
problème c'est protéger notre france
parce que c'est la france qui nous
importe et c'est important déjà te
mettre ça dans le débat public et d'en
parler et grâce à eric zemmour dans on
en parle mais aujourd'hui j'avais une
question plus générale
justement est ce qu'on n'est pas alors
que dans ce discours là il ya aussi un
peu l'idée que la france est au christ
qu'au tout va mal qu on est incapable de
défendre de valeur est-ce qu'il ya pas
un peu et je pense que c'est un rapport
avec le fait que au fond cette campagne
ne prend pas beaucoup on se fait
engueuler par tout le monde quoi partout
des candidats their tout va mal alors
c'est la faute des musulmans se font
engueuler les français soient en gueule
et tout le monde se faire engueuler
comme si c'était dans ce vrai comme si
il n'y a pas de ya pas de discours
peut-être que la candidature de mâcon un
peu d'espoir pas de d'avenir de quelque
chose de peu rayonnant à preuve il ya
vous saviez 11 route à part ou celles
non mais c'est vrai vous trouvez pas un
un discours un peu
dénoncer les dix premiers il n'y a rien
eu source d'espoir que de dénoncer les
difficultés et la difficulté on obéit
qui va plutôt bien économiquement le
sommer est en baisse il ya quand même
des réalités assez forte et là on a
l'impression qu'on est les derniers ddd
des crétins quoi nous ont écoutés
candidats pas des trains qui arrivent à
l'heure je vois pas un candidat qui m'a
dit ah bah oui nous sommes seuls animaux
on est les rois des sous c'est un bon
pour ça s'explique aussi les candidats
sont des candidats d'opposition
donc c'est un peu le c'est un peu le job
en guide reste plus beaucoup de temps
alors on rêve très vite alors mais
l'enjeu puisque voulez parler de 2,2
roussel est ce que la gauche c'est
maintenant chose d'abord au bois non
attendez il ya un digg à l'avant
[Musique]
garde à vue avec ségolène royal a été ce
rallye un deschamps pourrait dire après
tout si si vous êtes de gauche que vous
regardez un peu le marasme d'agos ou du
seul candidat qui a un peu de chance et
mais non sans quoi
non
28e' la gauche ça le vote utile à gauche
mais est ce que mélenchon c'est la
gauche enfin abassi généré si j'étais si
j'étais socialiste laïque 3 à des
publics issus je fais d'abord je le suis
d'ailleurs issus de l'époque des
lumières je me poserai peut-être la
question de savoir si ils représentatifs
avec la web culture là quand cette
culture est une forme islamo-gauchiste
l'attend face à sale nom
correspondraient pas je vois mal les
socialistes cuillère
salines de l'est et en plus ce qui est
fou dans ce mail c'est l'égalité un peu
de chose d'être au deuxième tour quoi
certes mais moi c'est pas parce que
quelqu'un a des chances d'être au
deuxième tour que j'ai envie de le
soutenir voyez ce que je patricio mais
si je suis de gauche de gauche encore
une fois républicain socialiste et
universaliste j'ai pas envie tout tribun
qu'il soit et même s'il vient de mes
rangs de voter pour jean luc mélenchon
jeu tant pis je préférais perdre la
présidentielle les soutenir alors le
problème c'est que j'aurais parlé pour
rien la ligue 1
je cherche et trouve quelqu'un m'avait
les costumes lamés
appel je partage je partage vraiment
cette opinion je pense que c'est même
royal apparaît gauchistes
je pense que je pense je pense que ségo
rial dit que jean luc virchaux est le
seul qui se trouve à gauche de
l'échiquier être capable de gagner voilà
après d'être capable de gouverner c'est
autre chose être capable de représenter
la gauche tels que la gauche
traditionnelle est socialiste
effectivement troisième république c'est
autre chose mais je pense que l à une
lucidité je pense c'est que c'est le
seul qui est capable aujourd'hui à
gauche de marquer nos positions et
emmanuel macron que qu'on soit d'accord
avec lui ou pas c'est pas la question
oui mais c'est lui qui a le plus de goût
alors déjà le plus de visibilité mais
aussi c'est lui c'est celui qui met le
plus en avance son opposition et anti
capitaliste anti anti tout si vous
voulez et finalement taxation sur les
profits répartie on a vu le l'entretien
de son
adriaco tenait
hier dans le point voilà cette vision de
la de la société qu'on soit d'accord ou
non je pense que c'est pour l'instant de
mélenchon qui est le plus capable de
c'est le seul capable à gauche en tout
cas de peut-être arrivé au deuxième tour
et hier je reviens au candidat préféré
de jean charles d'où d'ailleurs
l'accusation qui tombe sur
ou celle que russel de donc pour emplois
fictifs dans mediapart
très curieusement mediapart
accès d'emplois fictifs pourquoi parce
que russel c'est le seul qui peut
prendre des points à améliorer l'empêché
en effet d'être d'être au deuxième tour
est-ce que sansan roussel il peut être
dans les 15 % par milla la
chanson est le premier à dire faire des
appels du pied en disant au sel 95% de
nos idées sont compatibles voilà rejoint
- rejoins moi rejoint - est
effectivement comme par hasard cette
sorte de boule puante qui arrivent par
mediapart interposés je veux dire
maintenant le seul à nier l afrique a
tout intérêt à tuer si je peux dire
entre guillemets un fabien roussel voilà
mais bon cela dit à gauche c'est quand
même une heure avant l'appel à droite la
plus bête du monde on a aussi la gauche
la plus bête du monde parce que là ils
sont tous à se torpiller les uns les
autres quand on voit de cette pléthore
de candidats qui jouent au yo yo dans
les sondages
jadot qui était un moment peut quasiment
à 10% qui est complètement descendu
enfin je veux dire anne hidalgo qui a
jamais décollé mais enfin je veux dire
s'il y avait un tout petit frémissement
immédiatement torpillé par taubira qui
arrive enfin on dit à chaque fois il ya
une semaine c'est pas s'essayer du
secteur des mots
clés à 47 ou
croyez pas que la gauche ait finalement
est tombée en maladie si j'ose dire
quand ils ont quand ils ont oublié le
social pour le sociétal c'est à dire que
normalement il y avait une dégaine a
glissé une des raisons c'est terrible
c'était il ya la française à mon sens ce
qui est plus politique c'est le
torpillage du quinquennat dollon par les
fondeurs
je pense que là à partir de là la social
démocratie a pris les choses en main le
fait que l'on ne veuille pas affirmer ce
qui est et ce qui égalerait sa politique
qu'il ait voulu concéder tout le monde
et qui se soit près dé les fronts d'un
en pleine figure je pense que ça aussi
mais vous avez raison le social et théo
ont te ferais désigné pour le sociétal
et ça a été théorisée d'ailleurs
devraient d entendre notamment sur le
sort des agriculteurs sur les zones
rurales la ssp rentrée s'annonce
c'est
sur le sort des agriculteurs
après la vidéo hidalgo elle a quitté
paris elle a eu pied de nez de la france
c'est tout elle a été élue par les bobos
parisiens et et la minorité des bobos et
puis voilà donc mais la gauche aussi
perdu quand elle a abandonné la laïcité
à l'extrême ans actuellement et qui
était une notion fondamentalement
républicaine quand même aujourd'hui la
marque et le patriotisme et messieurs je
suis attristé tout à fait le siècle des
lumières être le 10 mai juin pose la
république sont alors que patrick
marchal de détruire
c'est pour dire qu'il ya un glissement
complètement
conduisait après il faudra mais on n'a
plus le temps est frais aussi se pencher
vous parliez de jaloux quand même
intéressant comme tout le monde vous dit
le grand problème des années qui
viennent c de réchauffement climatique
et que le candidat écolo et à 7% ça pose
peut-être
vous disais je termine juste là dessus
il ya 2 minutes vous me disiez on est
tout le temps en train de se faire
engueuler par les deux mondes extra est
les écolos notamment mais les écoles
n'arrête pas d'en violer toulouse et
fait les espaces et une vision du monde
en l'accusant lycée se suicider quand on
écoute jadot jeudi on peut pas y a pas
d'espoir il ya pas de truc c'est fini
voilà c'est même pas la peine de
continuer à faire de la télé des maisons
de vaud sévère on reste chez soi on
attend de s'endormir devant la roumaine
l'une des deux maisons à la campagne à
us à ses démons
reprise par les autres c'est comme si
moi je crée le parti de l'amour je pense
que vous serez tous adhérents mon parti
voilà oui alors donné sa laisse et
puisque tu n'es pas payé pas tant que
l'argent ce qu'il faudrait au logis est
un parti où les réponses qu'il n'ya pas
de parti de l'amour complet tous les cas
la moitié des problèmes qu'on voulait
forcer c'est normal merci beaucoup à
tous merci merci jean charest dit
laurent mazaury et raphaël mata du vidéo
et à très vite pour un autre numéro donc
de pas puisqu'il ya encore beaucoup de
choses à dire
[Musique]